let's do a little Deep dive behind the
scenes of firefly Lane to break down the
exact lines they kept from the book the
drama over Katherine Heigl's hair color
and Ben Lawson's struggle with the
Vancouver winter literally having to
fight off pneumonia during one of his
most romantic scenes obviously we know
the show was based on a book but how
close do they stick to it without saying
anything she grabbed Kate's arm pulled
her through the living room if you've
seen other shows based on books you
might be surprised to find out pretty
damn close everything was pink walls
cabinets curtains tile counters table a
significant portion of the dialogue is
verbatim to the book's narrative is that
your mom Kate asked uncertain of what to
say
she has cancer if you watch closely
you'll notice the little movements that
were narrated in the book as well Kate
glanced back at the door to the living
room
she doesn't care if you smoke for anyone
who read the book let me know in the
comments how spot-on you think the
show's interpretation is in the episode
where Johnny and Kate accidentally took
ecstasy ecstasy all right very funny I'm
not kidding there was a bit of movie
Magic involved as well as some Stellar
acting to really sell it
princess the telephone Bell is the
typewrite it's like music Turn It Up and
by movie Magic I really just mean some
contact lenses to make their pupils look
dilated apparently according to Ben
Lawson it was either they get the
contacts or they actually take the
Ecstasy for the scene the contact lens
Vibe just narrowly beat out the method
acting technique would have loved to see
it I'm just so glad that we had this
talk
he also said he put one of Kate's leg
warmers on his arm because he thought
that would be a totally normal thing to
do if you were high can't say I disagree
from what I've gathered about filming TV
shows and movies is that dinner scenes
are typically an all-day Affair and that
also proved to be true in Firefly Lane
there were also a ton of dinner scenes
in the most recent season but the reason
why it took so long to film is because
the cast loved to chat with one another
at the table following the move yes
following the Moon it doesn't really
matter yes and it was hard to get
anything done they would also mess
around and play little jokes on each
other too which obviously didn't help
shorten the workday Ben would show up to
set to film a scene and Ignacio would
make it well rather difficult for him to
sit down we love a good confessing your
love to someone in the rain moment maybe
not in the Vancouver Winter though that
I think I'd be able to do without I
think the weather was probably better in
the notebook no but yeah Ben Lawson and
Sarah chalk were absolutely struggling
in between Queen takes they had to be
wrapped up in a blanket the minute the
camera stopped rolling Ben shared his
behind the scenes insights basically
that he was trying his hardest not to
come down with pneumonia as he was
trying to deliver this deeply romantic
but like low-key cheesy speech in the
rain you're not too much
my love for you is too much I can't
imagine what would be more Awkward teeth
chattering during your romantic speech
or filming your first nude scene on a
kitchen counter we've got a lot to
unpack here this is the most that I've
ever done that like sex scene wise I've
never done this much Catherine Heigl
said she was only convinced because the
female director Ann wheeler sold the
scene to her with such artistic Vision
she's like I want to do the shot where
it's just your full naked back Catherine
though she had some insecurities about
doing those types of scenes at this
point in her career said she felt really
safe with and directing her it sounds so
beautiful and sexy and I would like to
believe that I can look beautiful and
sexy at 41. her only request was that
she get to see the final scene when it
was finished I've never been so naked on
a set before that was really
weird the Canadian winter was truly
putting these actors through the ringer
there's a scene where Sarah chalk has to
actually dive naked into a pool in the
freezing cold well if not now then when
I mean this is we're pushing the limit
here fun fact though every time the cast
had to wear essentially nothing they got
to choose their underwear and things
like that but yeah obviously even with
the freedom of choice when it came to
underwear it doesn't really protect you
from things like hypothermia when you
have to dive into a pool of freezing
cold water it did have blue lips
not a lot of clothing and blue lip I
think I need a bit of convincing that
being an actor is actually a fun job it
was absolutely uh part of the challenge
right Sarah chalk has a major sweet spot
for the 80s even before Firefly Lane so
when she landed the role she was totally
prepared for her first wardrobe fitting
and even brought in a bunch of her own
stuff I brought in some sweet stirrup
pants and an amazing acid wash pink jean
jacket to my first wardrobe fitting
there were a lot of 80s Vibes that they
got to get into Cyndi Lauper dressing up
as Madonna are you dressed like Madonna
which was actually like fulfilling a
childhood dream for her because she used
to dress up as Madonna a lot when she
was a teenager but now to have like a
professional team making you look
dressed up as Madonna Catherine Heigl
felt strongly about her character's
looks because she really wanted to stick
to the book's narrative I remember them
kind of being like Oh
in the book Tully has curly brown hair
so that's what Catherine wanted to look
like on screen I said I'm being a
brunette she's a brunette I must be a
brunette it ended up being this whole
debacle and they were low-key pushing
for Catherine to be a blonde but
obviously she wasn't having it and we
got the on-screen brunette Tully we all
know and love there was a bit more movie
Magic when it came to the portrayal of
the 19 year old version of Kate and
Tully obviously Catherine Heigl and
Sarah chalk didn't play the 14 year old
versions of their characters but
Catherine did give a little insight into
what it was like to play a 19 year old
in your 40s I was like do you guys have
good CGI because
yeah
at first they tried using face tape but
it was more cringe than youthful looks
like we've had very bad we can't close
our mouth so they turned to a bit of CGI
just to soften their faces a few touches
younger I don't know about you guys but
I love a good wig moment so I personally
love seeing all those fun 80s hairstyles
in the show the hair stylist Sarah cops
did a ton of research into the 80s hair
trends before creating the wigs the
theme for the wigs was essentially big
bangs and big hair Rowan Curtis who
played the 80s version of Kate has
always had the same hairstyle her whole
life so she got to have a lot of fun
being a woman of many wigs she said her
favorite look was the Dorothy Hamill wig
absolutely iconic you look like Velma
from Scooby-Doo it's it's actually a
Dorothy Hamill you might be surprised to
find out that one of the most difficult
things for the costume and makeup team
to keep up with was everyone's eyebrows
I can't say I took note of it but I kind
of want to go back and look at the brow
styles for each decade they were in they
wanted the eyebrows to represent as best
they could anyway the look of the decade
they were shooting for they kept going
back and forth between the 90s which the
vibe was a very thin brow and the 70s
which was pretty much the opposite so
they had a difficult time keeping it
consistent for every shot and speaking
of consistency they really had me fooled
that we were in Seattle this whole time
like I've mentioned above though they
shot most of the show in Vancouver they
filmed across the seawell water walk and
in local places like Gastown bar it was
also filmed in Langley a small town just
an hour outside of Vancouver which Ron
Curtis a Vancouver native who has lived
there her entire life had never even
been before
Firefly Lane's big theme is friendship
which is extremely obvious that doesn't
end when the camera stop rolling those
long dinner time chats say a lot it's
also clear that sticking to the book is
super important for the actors and the
writers as well as keeping those
specific decade styles on point what was
your favorite behind the scenes moment